comme chaque troisième jeudi du mois de
novembre les adeptes du beaujolais
nouveau attendent avec impatience sa
sortie officielle le coin du sommelier
barre avant de maurepas est les
templiers restaurant gastronomique
d'elancourt viennent de s'associer
il propose un concept plus élargie il
dispose à présent d'une vraie cave à vin
plaisir d'avoir notre cave en fait dans
le restaurant c'est de pouvoir faire
partager notre passion du vin à nos
clients et de pouvoir leur faire
accorder leur mais que ce soit du canard
que ce soit de la viande que ce soit du
poisson avec toute la multitude de ces
pages qu'on a aucun restaurant et coin
du sommelier 600 références sont
proposées aux clients
on va démarrer avec le près 450
références de vins une cinquantaine de
références de champagne et entre 150 et
200 références de spiritueux donc quand
je parle de spiritueux je parle de rome
de whisky de tequila de chin dans tous
les alcools qui dépasse 18 degrés les
prix des bouteilles varie de 6 euros et
peuvent monter jusqu'à 1000 euros pour
les grands crus classés si la bouteille
et consommer sur place un droit de
bouchon de 15 euros est alors appliqué
on peut venir ici à la cave acheter sa
bouteille
donc le prix qu à vis comme tout le
monde comme si on allait chez un caviste
indépendants ou alors on reste ici et à
ce moment là on a plus que le droit de
bouchon si on conserve la bouteille sur
place si on termine pas sa bouteille
bien évidemment on peut repartir avec
une dégustation est proposée aux
templiers à la commanderie de
lavilledieu d'elancourt demain à
l'occasion du beaujolais nouveau de
18h30 à 22h avec des animations